Richard Rip Hamilton Intel true VR and
NBA on team NBA on TNT VR that's what
you're here joining before we talk about
that one though rich why you're here I'm
still caught up and sorry man because
I'm caught up in what happened with
Kevin Durant and I'm thinking I'm never
was an NBA player but I've seen in my
NFL career injuries to marquee players
and then all of a sudden it's like oh oh
what do we do now
so last night as I'm watching the game
Kevin Durant goes down rip and have you
been in a situation like that where a
player of that magnitude on your team
goes down and it's like what do we do oh
man that was definitely a hard dropping
moment if I'm klay Thompson or Steph
Curry
I mean you got a guy that pretty much
looked at it at as being unguardable
like he's the only guy that you have on
your team if definitely making shots and
clay making shots and you know dream I
can't get in the paint and make plays
Katie's the only guy on your team that
you can throw the ball to and they say
alright everybody get out the way give
me a bucket that's the luxury of Kevin
Garnett on this incredible team already
so yes I do think it's gonna have an
effect on them can they still get
through this series yes I mean you still
got a two-time MVP and Steph Curry and
do I believe that a do stuff carry take
take a backseat sometimes because the KD
you know similar to the way did and in
Miami when LeBron James got there yeah I
can see that is their level is their
higher levels that Steph Curry can get
to without a chest so I do think yes
it's a heart dropping moment but I still
believe that goes they still can get to
the final but how do you do it on the
road though it's one thing to play at
home and to have the situation happen
with Kevin Durant you still win the game
and you have this luxury now right you
go on the road knowing you just got to
win one of the next two games but how do
you handle it on the road so it doesn't
it doesn't get to a game seven
well I think that first down you know
everybody's going to write them off
right now goes they saying it
this right guaranteed gamers Houston
Rockets is going to get so I look at it
saying the pressure is more on Houston I
mean how about Houston how about if
you're James Harden a guy that could be
a two-time MVP and Chris Paul like never
you know him being injured last year not
get an opportunity play it again seven
so I think it's more pressure on dumb
guys than it is to go and State Warriors
because the playoffs is all about you
know the the playoffs don't really start
in until the first team goes on their
home court especially with the team that
has home court advantage so forever it's
like our you know what we got a three to
mean we only need to get one all the
pressure is going to be on you sir we
just got to come out there and play have
fun move the ball and hopefully they can
get higher when you got two of the best
shooters in the world anything could
happen
these Rip Hamilton NBA champion joins us
on behalf of Intel true VR and NBA on
TNT VR we'll get to more of that a
little bit later rip but my next
question for you would be I want to
shift over more toward the Eastern
Conference obviously the Boston Celtics
lost yesterday and they have been
eliminated but what I'm seeing from Jana
Santa to come in Waukee bucks
I sort of likened it a little bit to a
young LeBron James a guy who you saw in
the Eastern Conference as he kind of
rose to start him fairly quickly which
we already knew he had that expectation
but you saw a young LeBron trying to put
a team on his back and get to a finals
you played against that guy
is there similarities between the two
Yanis and LeBron right now what you're
seeing in these playoffs oh yes most
definitely and I'm sad that I got a
visit that we felt would seem crappy
like I'm still going to the back of my
hair right now but yes when you think
about it you know I think LeBron in the
situation where we were in Detroit we
felt like like we were the the last
level of defense for LeBron to get to
the NBA Finals and if he got the rust
and oh my goodness sky's the limit for
him and you can see in this his his
career and how much success he had after
beating us and yeah
very similar you know Jonas has that it
factor especially when it comes to
superstardom and being the main guy in
the locker room to see this true see
doesn't take any days off if you talk to
people in organizations in Milwaukee
they gotta kick him off the court
especially during holidays like he's got
us there
New Year's Eve and there's your days
working working on his game and that's
great especially when the guy is so
young you know a lot of times it it
takes young players to grow into that
role and especially on a young team he
gots that with it he's not trying to
work out with other individuals he's not
trying to hang out with other guys he's
not trying to be cool he's trying to win
you see him in an all-star game
seems like he's the only guy in Austin
you playing hard yeah you know he's the
guy in all-star game that's trying to
compete so I don't think he has a off
switch when it comes to that in
transition very similar to LeBron James
I mean you got to build a wall like you
don't use one foot in the paint it's a
dunk you know and now the game has
changed so it's gonna have the
traditional bigs no more right you don't
have Rasheed Wallace Ben Wallace Ben mm
the security security blanket when
you're talking about defense like you
get past me and tayshon of Chauncey you
still got a battle with the big boys now
when you look at teams teams are going
small right there
their center is now either the small
fort or the power forward that power
forward is usually the small forward of
the two guard you know so so easy honest
gets past the first boy he's a lot
bigger stronger then the guy that's on
the last less part of your defense right
so uh I mean he's arguably one guard
while he's my pick for the MVP NBA
champion Rip Hamilton join the Rich
Eisen show Kirk Morrison filling in for
rich and I'm thinking back to when
you're Detroit Pistons team kind of came
together the NBA champion team and I
look at the game tonight in these series
between Toronto and Philadelphia and I'm
gonna stick with Philadelphia because if
a couple young guys and Ben Simmons
obviously
JoEllen b-but you bring in the Jimmy
Butler the Tobias Harris and you're
saying that here's some guys still
developing that chemistry how did you
guys develop that chemistry kind of
pretty quickly to a point where if
there's some advice you can give Joelle
and B Ben Simmons because these two guys
have been so up and down in this series
and I think we expect more from them so
what advice would you give these guys in
especially a game 6 situation well first
of all you gotta understand that when
you're in a playoffs right I think Larry
Brown just always this is this cool
analogy about the whole thing he used to
say all right you know what when we get
to the playoffs guys hey I understand
this they already picked their all-star
team believe me the artikpix
all-stars over already had our all-stars
out there right sir guys'll pick certain
guys aren't they already got in their
mind the votes when it comes to all-nba
teams and everything else right
everybody's playing for one thing right
now and that's winning a championship so
it's not about your individual success
is how can you make your teammates
better and how can you be productive on
the floor doing what you do at the best
of your Billy don't do someone else's
job or you know try to critique someone
else out there if they play your game
and I'll put you in all all the right
spots on the floor don't worry about all
the outside noise and when you're a
young team you're a young group there's
always a lot of outside noise that can
affect your game on the court right they
could be saying like are you know what
rolling beat against them but this is
you guys should begin more shots than
Jimmy Butler and Tobias Harris right and
they should be building around that
that's outside no one's that can the
same a young a young team I do feel like
a you know what chemistry wise they have
got better over the season but they're
still not there some some games and
Sixers look great some games Sixers look
alright you know and I think a lot of
that has to be with chemistry you know
still learning each other because they
argue ly got probably the second best
start five in in the league right and
most of these guys when you talk about
Jimmy and Tobias they were outfit
on her teams like God that they were
running off his legal scores and now
you're coming on the team now that
probably has one of most dominant
players in our game and Joel and be the
guy that could demand the ball every
time down the floor right so a similar
to my business team we were good right
right
without Rossi Wallace but when we got
Rossi Wallace man we were great like
like we were unstoppable like like okay
like being a chalky then used to come
off pick the rolls and 10,000 like oh
they can't double-team this now why
because they got to worry about rush is
on the on the Flair's you gotta watch
uh-huh Rachid ducking in like you only
got to worry about been going it off as
a glass so now you got five guys on the
court that can all play that team's got
to be aware of so I think that if with
the Sixers understand hey it's okay to
make the hockey pads out there it's okay
for someone else to run the office it's
okay for me maybe to come out and take
five or six shots and only have ten
points because I got three other guys on
this team or four other guys other team
taking go out we give me 30 forgive me
for so it's not all about the
individuals it's all about the team riff
Hamilton the NBA champion joins us from
Intel true VRE and NBA on TNT VR I'm
still gonna get to that in one second
rip but I got to think back to your 2004
NBA champion team again the Detroit
Pistons because they took down a dynasty
in the Los Angeles Lakers with Kobe Shaq
Karl Malone a team that people thought
was a run away with the NBA Finals you
guys went in there you mentioned it
yourself or she been Chauncey tyshaun
and I'm looking maybe at the Houston
Rockets as they are trying to take down
another dynasty in the Warriors now -
Kevin Durant but the way that you guys
attacked it what was your mindset along
with what you mentioned the outside
noise how did you leave that outside
noise outside of the locker room as well
well first of all we wasn't scared
the Lakers can be very intimidated
tonight hosting was I mean Lakers have
four Hall of Famers right right but in
in our mind we felt like we were
that's five alive and nothing could take
that away from was like and we had dog
like like we were like pitbull was like
are you know what we we all felt like we
came from different situations where
teams gave up on like our you know we're
just going to Detroit right and then we
all got together and we all had that
same story we all felt like we're in the
foxhole together right
outside of Detroit there's a lot of
people that don't believe that we can
win at all but we just fell so that the
chemistry was right like I knew
Chauncey's game inside and out
he knew my game inside and out and it
was weird because we were only playing
together for two years then like a year
and a half uh she came mid season but it
was a thing that we all respected each
other and we all tried to protect each
other like we were brothers so Rachid
win let down Ben Wallace so uh she had
to guard whoever right Karl Malone he
knew that our I got a girl called Malone
head up you know because I I don't want
to let my brother down by getting in
foul trouble or doing stupid plays out
there getting technical fouls or
anything like that
you know because it would affect my
brother intersect his job and how he
does his job right right so it just it
was a big thing off respect we all
believe that you know we were great like
me and Chauncey felt like we were the
best backcourt elite from day one Russia
even Ben thought they were the best
you know frontcourt in the NBA they sell
feel like he can guard anybody out there
on the floor right and took a step back
offensively so we can be great so the
team can be great so which is all about
sacrificing guys understood each other
and we just wouldn't let each other down
we felt like we were the best we didn't
go and say it all right you know what
the Lakers are the best data cream with
a crime no the Pistons is that's what we
believe
NBA champion Rip Hamilton join the Rich
Eisen show Kirk Morrison filling in for
rich but you're joining us on behalf of
Intel true VR and NBA on TNT VR tell us
about it well yes it's cool Intel sports
uh brings fans closer to the game
through virtual reality which is which
is awesome so you can kind of
you to game through oculus goggles and
you can use the Samsung device also to
kind of view the game and what it does
it kind of brings the experience the NBA
experience of going to the game inside
your house so you can kind of sit on
your couch you can wear your pajamas you
can be outside you know wherever there's
Wi-Fi capabilities and view the game and
feel like you're there on the floor
watching the game I always said when I
was a kid I wish I had something like
this because my parents couldn't afford
to spend as much money would on a floor
on the floor seat and the goggles allow
you to get that experience there you
know you kind of see the stuff from like
angles that you wouldn't be able to see
on a normal telecast and I'm and I'm
yeah and I'm able to man stuff get ready
my clothes we're able to direct you
through that you know through that
transition all the different camera
angles and giving you a more like in
creative experience when it comes to you
know talking to game and it's not just
all about analytics we're kind of like
bringing you in the locker room and just
having like a conversation which we do
storytelling and to tell you exactly
what's going on in the game too so it's
a fun experience also able to access in
game data in game data and free and is
available to download from the oculus
store correct yes yes you can go on
oculus store you can download the NBA
tnt VR app and I want to download that
you go to the local cable described
prescriber and then you put your
information there and you've got it I
rip I appreciate the time and definitely
going to check it out and I look forward
to talking to you soon and get some more
your thoughts may I appreciate it and
also to the ad that I could allow Kobe
Bryant
trust me since you beat them the Lakers
they've won a couple championships but
really quick now I know we got to take a
break here boo just in ten seconds with
what's going on in Los Angeles in 10
second how do you just
right that well like a citizen mess
inside because the Lakers are probably
arguing best and when when you got a
magic step it down he's got cheat Lou
not accepting the job I mean early
season we're talking about LeBron James
being MVP and then being able to be in
the top three seed and if he doesn't get
hurt it's a whole new different of it
it's a whole different kind of creature
now all this stuff all came about a trip
man appreciate the time as always never
catch up with you soon yeah that's where
Pamela's an NBA champion joining us on
behalf of Intel sports true VR and NBA
on TNT VR as well for more of the Rich
Eisen show tune
- audience Channel 239 on DirecTV for
free on VR live or download the Rich
Eisen show app